our views are going down and so what we
need to do is get some fresh information
a fresh perspective and invest in doing
a fresh study there's a new set of
problems so you need a new content
strategy to evolve with the world with
your subscribers with what's happening
on YouTube so here's a few ideas of how
you could switch things up and try
something new
if your YouTube views have been going
down you're not alone we've been getting
a lot of feedback Lately from creators
and entrepreneurs in all different
industries that their views are down
their channels kind of in a plateau and
that they are feeling stuck so in this
episode of the think media podcast I
want to share with you three powerful
strategies for how to revive your
channel get views going again and switch
things up if you feel like you're in a
rut number one evaluate your YouTube
channel with fresh eyes I was reading a
book recently called decisive and one of
the strategies for making better
decisions is attain distance before
deciding what can happen with YouTube is
we get so close to the problem we get so
emotionally wrapped up in our channel
that it can be hard to have a sober
perspective and clear thinking when it
comes to really looking at the health of
our channel so the first thing I would
suggest when seeing a slump in views on
your channel is attaining distance
getting a thirty thousand foot
perspective and asking some questions
could the degrees and Views be related
to seasonality perhaps it's summer and
Views go down for a lot of channels
during summer is it the season of the
content of your channel maybe it's going
to be higher around January or December
around the holidays and maybe it's going
to be lower at other times of the year
what are some of the factors that could
be influencing your views attaining
distance could also look like asking
yourself what is the landscape of my
Niche and topic how has that changed for
some seasoned creators who maybe have
been consistently creating content year
after year but now your views are going
down well chances are there could be
more creators and more options around
that type of content today and as a
result maybe the views are being
distributed across multiple channels
furthermore in general there is just
more content options it's not about
having a direct competitor it's about
realizing that you're competing with
Netflix and Hulu and Max and these other
platforms that people can give their
attention to additionally have you done
a deep dive audit of your YouTube
analytics to see what you can find what
are the videos and topics that are
performing best on your channel and what
videos are not performing as well are
you in a rut or a slump of content in
general have you been repeating yourself
a lot maybe creating content formats
that are not resonating with your
audience you want to attain distance
first we want to gather some information
and if possible we want to Tamp down our
emotions a little bit to try to just
have an accurate look at the state of
the channel the state of the market get
that 30 000 foot perspective so that
you're not wrapped up in being too close
to the problem number two do a fresh
study of YouTube culture in your
industry when is the last time that
you've went down a research Rabbit Hole
when it comes to your topic in Industry
overall for me my industry is the
creator of economy my industry is video
marketing my industry is YouTube for
many creators they haven't actually
clearly defined their industry yet to
figure out what Publications events
meetups workshops newsletters exist in
your industry once you've defined those
when was the last time you actually put
some time aside attain distance before
deciding and invested some time in doing
a fresh study reading about things maybe
having some conversations with other
creators other peers perhaps joining a
mastermind again we get in a rut our
views are going down and so what we need
to do is get some fresh information a
fresh perspective and invest in doing a
fresh study what's happening in The
Wider culture what are some of the
competing topics perhaps if at one point
in Fitness CrossFit was blowing up but
now it's shrinking down in popularity
could that be because another workout or
type of Fitness or trend is is blowing
up the conclusion you make may be to
still double down on your channel and
your video topic but at least now you're
getting insights because you're doing a
broader study of the wider culture but
even beyond your Niche what's happening
in culture YouTube overall what are some
of the Trends on YouTube there was the
arrow where Vlogs were really blowing up
now they're not blowing up as much and
I'm not trying to come to any
conclusions for you I'm just encouraging
you to study to consider what content
formats are maybe tired could you
ultimately switch things up which brings
us to number three and that is try
something new I love this quote from the
military General Sun Tzu and it says
this do not repeat the tactics which
have gained you one Victory but let your
methods be regulated by an infinite
variety of circumstances this is a rich
quote because a lot of content creators
keep repeating the one tactic that
worked one time and got them one Victory
not not realizing that there is a lot of
different variables a lot of different
circumstances again there might be
something happening in politics maybe
we're in an election cycle maybe a lot
of people's attention has been diverted
from a particular type of content the
move could be to just stay committed to
Excellence stay patient don't give up
stay in business keep your YouTube
channel alive because things are
seasonal and it'll come back once that
Trend or cultural season ultimately ends
but we can never rely on the one tactic
or the one content format that worked
yesterday we need to let our methods be
regulated by an infinite variety of
circumstances so here's a few ideas of
how you could switch things up and try
something new this video was brought to
you by stream yard stream yard is our
go-to platform for streaming to YouTube
and Facebook with an incredibly easy to
use interface for built-in branding
transitions text lower thirds and
seamlessly bringing on guests it really
is one of the best options when it comes
to live streaming and what's so cool is
they've implemented a brand new feature
called local recording take control of
your audio and video with local
recordings by separating out your audio
and video from your guests this feature
gives you the control over your content
for later use making it perfect for
podcasts and video creators just go to
streamwoodthink.com to get started now
one example is changing up your content
format content formats include talking
head videos vlogging as a style of video
and I don't mean like all of a sudden
you start doing a daily Vlog I mean that
instead of just sitting at your desk
creating content you take your camera
and you maybe teach through the subject
matter while you're in multiple
different locations you're moving around
there's maybe a little more story to it
a change of scenery another content
format could be teaching in front of a
whiteboard another content format could
be doing almost like a webinar or a web
class and teaching off of a PowerPoint
another content format could be faceless
where you're not on camera but you just
have a voiceover and there's b-roll
throughout the video another content
format could be leaning into fair use
content where you are narrating and
sharing through a story but then there's
other sound bites and video clips from
movies or TV shows or other YouTube
videos the point is not to go through an
exhaustive list of content formats it's
the fact that we can oftentimes get into
a rut or maybe always sitting in the
same place talking head video doing the
same thing and if you're doing the same
thing and your views are going down we
should try something new another example
of this could be pivoting your topic now
what I'm not suggesting is that you
change your entire channel topic or
switch your entire Channel Niche that
may be necessary at some point but when
I say pivot your channel topic I think a
better word for that would be an
evolution how could your content evolve
what is the 2.0 version the 3.0 version
of your current channel one story that
comes to mind is my friend Judy Travis
Benji Travis is the co-author of our
book YouTube Secrets the second edition
is out now and if you haven't read
YouTube secrets that actually would be a
very good book to help you if your views
are going down and we'll link that up
it's on Amazon and audible in the
description down below but Benji and I
co-wrote that book Benji's wife Judy
Travis had a channel originally called
It's Judy's time and it was a makeup and
Beauty Channel and what she did was she
started early on in YouTube when there
was a lot of kind of makeup channels
starting but when you think about makeup
in general it was sort of open-ended
there's a lot of niches within that
Niche you could of course do and forgive
me I don't know all the terminology here
but you could do smokey eye tutorials or
you could also do Foundation stuff or
you could also do hair stuff or you also
could do nails I mean a lot of things
around Beauty And the tagline of her
channel was it's Beauty time with its
Judy's time and ultimately that was kind
of a clear Niche but it gave her some
creative playground internally to figure
out maybe different types of videos that
she could do it didn't have to be all
makeup and one of the things that
evolved on her channel was she found a
particular content format that really
worked for her she's doing makeup
tutorials and at the time a lot of
people were but then she started to do
some heritage tutorials and she noticed
those resonated even deeper so she
doubled down on hair the key here was
that Judy's channel was evolving and she
was experimenting with different topics
that were still clearly around the same
category it's not like she decided one
day to say you know what I'm going to
switch to Minecraft Gameplay tutorials
or something like that she just kind of
started going away more from makeup more
into hair and continued to evolve on her
Channel what would the next level of
evolution for your channel look like
perhaps you've been talking about
software or Tech in some way and now ai
is coming and so Ai and all the AI
software and the different things that
are happening there that would be the
evolution that didn't even exist a
couple months ago ultimately it's
growing in popularity and so the
pivoting of your topic would be asking
the question what did my subscribers
originally subscribe for what are they
thinking about right now what are their
new problems what are the new issues
issues that are keeping them up at night
the viewers and subscribers on my
channel what's stressing them out what
are they thinking about now for every
problem they've solved think about how
audiences age and grow and audiences
evolve are you evolving with them are
the problems you used to be solving on
your channel less relevant today and
there's a new set of problems so you
need a new content strategy to evolve
with the world with your subscribers
with what's happening on YouTube and so
perhaps this is an opportunity to launch
a new channel or just completely change
your channel topic or Niche and that's a
conversation for another day but my
suggestion is that all of us should
probably be evolving and pivoting our
topic honoring our current subscribers
but taking it to the 2.0 or 3.0 version
and actually I do have some answers for
you right now in case you're wondering
Sean do I need to actually completely
change my Niche completely change my
topic and the third opportunity would be
yes to change your channel topic so you
could experiment with different formats
you could just pivot and evolve your
channel but perhaps maybe this YouTube
channel this topic has ran its course
and it's time to start something
entirely new not just within your
channel but on let's say a new channel
and I actually have a whole episode on
that it's on how to know when to quit
YouTube this is a must watch episode and
we'll link it up in the description down
below hint it's not that you would
necessarily quit YouTube overall but it
could mean that you quit the current
topic or channel that you're working on
that episode of the think media podcast
shares multiple insights for how to
decide if you should stick with your
current topic Double Down perhaps pivot
and it's all based on a book from Seth
Godin called the dip it's a lot of
people's favorite episode in our library
and so of course you can check it out on
audio in the show notes or the link to
the YouTube video in the show notes as
well now if you also want some more help
and your views are going down and you
haven't watched our free on-demand class
at thinkmasterclass.com that is
absolutely your next best step the truth
is on the other side of you just sucking
it up getting a better strategy and
taking Massive Action you can have some
breakout videos and get some views
before you get too abstract and too emo
worrying about if you should quit or not
you probably should go watch this class
and just put out a few bangers over the
next month following the step-by-step
tips that you're going to learn we
actually talk about the one strategy we
use at think media that's generating
over 350 000 views every single day
whether we upload new videos or not and
this class is free it's an hour long and
it's on demand at thinkmasterclass.com
so if you want to check out any of the
past episodes on think media including
that episode on how to know when to quit
YouTube that's in the show notes if you
haven't watched that free on-demand
class that's in the show notes as well
or you can type in the URL
thinkmasterclass.com if you got value
out of this episode it would mean the
world to me if you like rate and review
this episode of the think media podcast
wherever you watch or listen to it and I
can't wait to connect with you on the
next episode